[Musique]
qui veut parler d'argent avec moi ça
c'est moi technal
peta ailleurs bordeaux et les chaussures
merdique blanc donne peut-être pas l'air
mais je suis une arnaqueuse la besoins
deviennent jamais je suis sympa je suis
fans de bieber
j'me fais des tas de copines aussi je te
promets que je te défonce ta sale gueule
c'est pas si mal
on n'a pas les moyens payés ça il faut
arrêter d'essayer moins pauvres qui
trouvait le moyen de devenir riche
quelle est la différence entre une fuite
est un collector de dead j'adore ces
plaques une pile tu prends ton fric
avant te fourrer d'accomplir des
collectrices d'été supplier pour
soulager les gens c'est un sentiment
extraordinaire de trouver enfin sa vraie
vocation soldé votre bête pour faire
baisser votre stress et provoqué une
montée de lait pour nourrir votre bébé
il était temps de voler de mes propres
ailes tu voyais toujours plus grand plus
grand je veux transformer la tête en
profite alléluia bon et se doit sur ces
cinq territoires et se chie dessus parce
qu'ils savent qu'on va les battre on va
leur faire fermer leurs boutiques
c'est la guerre
tapant dit tu te casses des mamans tu
craques solaire du genre de femme qui
cherche à se caser
tu es stressé
il voulait la guerre j'allais la gagner
sans menace sans intimidation
[Musique]
vais retourner en prison
non
[Musique]
pourquoi vous ne m'aviez pas parler de
ce petit ans
[Musique]